yo tout le monde c'est spécial champions
se trouve sur happy wheels et attention
j'avais déjà fait deux vidéos sur ce jeu
il ya à peu près un an c'est à dire
quand j'avais sept têtes
pourquoi tuerie explique moi pourquoi tu
rigoles trêve c'est parti bodjoma elsa
laurent par moyens nouveaux personnages
en plus de ça ok qui s'est offerte à
domicile blague ou quoi là mais le
niveau est buggé quoi je touche à rien
bref date se fait ça et ce bo5
excite tous médias et les copains lebel
un thonier object ok on n'y va pas
je sens je sens que ok non à ça va être
moins qu'une jambe c'est bon tu avais
besoin de gens pour piloter apparemment
au qui a cru qui a cru sa mère allait
[ __ ] c'est bon on a réussi ouais ok ok
ça le faire ça le problème est qu'il ya
un problème avec les pictaves on dirait
qu'il est posé comme s'il était sur son
canapé quoi il ya aucun problème
tu mets une télé devant lui et voilà ils
s'éclatent bonbons 1ère partie est ce
qu'on ressent que le speed run bon sens
la conduite du mec plutôt prudents c'est
bon breaking all again en irak
voilà qui est bon c'est bon c'est pas
comme si on avait été cassé en morceaux
le tri qui revient pour nous trop les
eaux non ok on sent le rex père à
l'hôpital était plié en deux quoi on
aurait dit un sandwich homme est un
homme il est pas mort il dort comme ça
c'est d'homme habitat j'ai cru qu'ils
étaient sur des toilettes j'ai carrément
hallucinant
qu'est ce qu'on fait maintenant
qu'est-ce qu'on est s'il vous plaît
aidez-moi à hasnon salut mes pieds
comment ça va s'il vous plaît j'ai
besoin d'eux arrêtes ta à position
foetale maintenant je m'en fous je me
suis amusé à brouiller le problème c'est
n'importe quoi bon faire tourner c'est
l'heure des peuples le peuple peut pique
ross ohlendorf j'avais un [ __ ] de
curling à mon bras je t'aime et non pas
chat c'est il le faut adieu mon bras
à aubigny il est revenu pour nouveau il
est tellement vidéo table et rick vert
non non non non non non je m'en fous
j'ai pas toujours dansé du daft punk
[Musique]
peut-être pas en fait on va tenter une
dernière fois
parce que j'aime relever des défis
plutôt diverses et variées chez bamba le
steak j'ai continué sa maison de a à a
heureusement que j'ai un gros bidon pour
faire contrepoids à à mieh s'il vous
plaît jeunes ballot
venez dans ma main apparemment n'est pas
très bon en plus tous ces trois cerveaux
boussu et tout comme ça maintenant j'ai
un truc dans dirt et les chipmunks coup
ça merde on va leur faire très bien très
bien
boîte ah oui timide est très bien balazs
wiki murray me saouler victory hockey en
bassa s'accouplent de manière plutôt
plutôt bord non moi je veux le mettre la
balle à juste mais [ __ ] mais je vais
jamais rsa apa dont voilà il est sympa
tant de mots bénisse khayame jambes qui
danse que boogie woogie mais moi en
attendant je n'ai plus de sam
s'il vous plaît je suis coincée dans un
bocal oh quelle utilité 0 williams à
paula profite du soleil jeune homme faut
survivre à la chute je sais pas comment
os à lui ok on a fait une sorte
d'accouplement bizarre mais on peut y
arriver on est en rien vous dire oh
[ __ ] de prise ou un 1 1 à 1
oh oh là là holla holla technique à la
technique de drague nom au jeu de
travail je t'ai treuil
alors pendant mes problèmes c'est
dégueulasse arrête mais à je sais que tu
lâches lâche ton copain prend la prends
la peep pièce oui absolument retourner
vers lui il ya un truc s'est passé
quelque chose entre ces deux là avant
qui tombe
oui
papa c'est quand qu'on arrive la donne à
vos questions ce faire une prise de
catch ou à base de à moi la taille c'est
quoi cette hockey attention champions
équilibristes depuis 1972 au kent on
arrête là ouais king ball à [ __ ] au
caire trois canaux rôle dans le canon
canada tu dis tu dis si tu veux pas de
deux mois fin tu me le dis a pas de
programme quaero voilà on est rentré un
canon on y va j'aime me mets en position
foetale allait jeter plus de jambes
allez on sent pas bon sauf si plus cette
injustice de ouf le regard des gros
sauvage suis-je pas du tout comme tiens
tiens me dit tiens on peut pas le
prendre avec me suis là attendez on va
tenter mais puisqu'on peut prendre les
gens avec ce truc informations à tout va
c'est plutôt possible de la voir merde
c'est pas grave au niveau position
foetale ya pas de problème ah non non
non non non ce qu'est le mec son sort et
il va thème les pics qu'est ce qui à
quoi tu veux que je te porte par la peau
du dos aux 6,1 et ben tiens tiens
je suis super man j'ai dit je suis super
mal 90% mpossible challenge kiabi les
pertes avant impôts en baisse
dad vs grande pas ok sa partie viendra
gonfler j'ai mon sabre
non je suis planté donne a dans les
faits ça fait mal sortez pas chapero
quelques heures à bamako ni ok il
s'envola vers d'autres cieux
non mais sans déconner j'aimerais bien
le a non ok moi pas du tout m vers la
non je sais pas pourquoi le sable on
finira toujours d'action dans ces
[ __ ] de fesses bien non en eau il
n'est pas dans nos fesses pour une fois
c'est incroyable ce qui se passe non pas
les fesses pas les fesses
palmor pas le montant non plus global
steak on va la voir on va l'avoir
j'attends de voir
house home brouillard le bogue ce qui
veut dire incroyable boc devrait
sérieusement qu'il n'a pas compris
l'exercice mme parcours 3d watts j'ai
juste avant ses ecchymoses a cassé une
jambe à mon fils ton papa n'a pas le dos
cassé je te jure
arrête de pédaler tu écrases des gens
très bien peuvent grâce taseer g chypre
espèces du genre magnette par mon ami et
je m'en vais sans toi c'est parti tout
va bien dit ne t'en fais pas baird tibet
j'ai pêché par hugo chavez c'est bon je
te tiens toi ok faut que je fasse
attention et puis ceux d'en bas il
essaie d'attraper timide on n'aurait
jamais dit mais au fond tout aux [ __ ]
merde a été trop longue
timée par jimmy guette hélicoptère un
push the object in the box attendait les
objets c'est ses papiers ok très bien
voilà deux pour le prix d'un c'est
gratuit a en plus son opposition un
petit peu délicate c'est gratuit c'est
pour moi ya pas de problème oh merde
pardon devant dieu à l'oreille je suis
désolé sans histoire dont presque désolé
il y avait un problème s'il te plaît à
temps et c'est plus tard pour moi désolé
les gens du coup je peux plus jouer à un
pee wee j'espère quand même ça vous aura
plu à parce que ça faisait un an qu'on
n'avait pas fait de la pub où il ce qui
fait que ça tape quand même ses pouvoirs
à cette merveilleuse tête de moi d'il ya
un an sur ce je vous dis à bientôt je
fais plein de bisous
tous et caetera et caetera et portez
vous bien elle se retourne tous saluent
attention on va mettre un coucou des
cagoules sur tout
avant tu m'as trahi